[موسيقى]
20% من الناس وهي على قائمه الانتظار
بتموت او بتخرج بره القائمه ليه يعني
تدهورت حالتهم نتيجه طول الانتظار فما
يستحملش عمليه كبيره فيموت هيخرج ومش
هيزرع وهيموت
[موسيقى]
فكره جات لي وانا عندي 16 سنه
لانه ما كنتش سمعت انها موجوده بره
ولقيتها يعني فكره منطقيه وحلوه وبتدي
فرصه للحياه من لا شيء من لا شيء ممكن كذا
بني ادم يعيش من ولا حاجه
هو حقيقي
عايشين ايه ده الروعه دي ايه الجمال ده
يعني
[موسيقى]
الحقيقه ان الملف زراعه الاعضاء من
الملفات الهامه جدا
التي
تتابع بشكل مباشر من فخامه السيد الرئيس
ومن الملفات التي يحدث للدكتور خالد عبد
الغفار وزير الصحه والسكان على
استكمال كل ما بيها اا من امور فنيه وامور
مرتبطه كان عندنا قانون في مصر وصدر في
سنه 2010
هاعمل الحقيقه القانون ده كان في ذلك
الوقت يعتبر فتح في التشريعات الخاصه
بدراعات الاعضاء
اا لكن خلال الفتره اللي فاتت ال12 سنه
الممارسه العمليه اا اختصرت على بعض اجزاء
من الخروج
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]